good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday theo is
front and center today to wish you all a
happy friday friday gotta get down on
friday
everybody is looking forward to the
weekend more than ever it's a long one
it's a holiday one it's the last one of
summer which is such a beautiful
statement i feel like for i've been
conditioned to like resent this time of
the year so
deeply like back to school no back to
school yes and i am unlearning all of
that hatred because today was sick it's
65 degrees it's gorgeous outside
gorgeous i'm gonna go to the park it
makes you just want to be outside for
the sake of it which is a feeling i
haven't been able to really truly relate
to probably since may yeah i think the
last time i enjoyed being when is
rebecca rittenberg's birthday march okay
maybe march when she had an outdoor
birthday party i was like oh this is
nice we should spend more time outside
yeah but i haven't really felt that
since then no i i feel you
wholeheartedly it's a beautiful day it's
a beautiful time of year and we're just
enjoying falling into fall
and so thank you summer good day sir see
you
in like a year i don't even think i'm
falling into fall i'm like steamrolling
into fall i'm falling
falling is that supposed to be
hairstyles i think so yeah i mean the
melody was like slightly off but i knew
what you were trying to do
i could feel it
thank you um so we have an interesting
show for you guys today because there's
so many things going on first of all
there's nothing going on literally like
jackie can you do what you just did
before and read the top five trending
stories on peoplemagazine.com i would
love to you guys so you can understand
what we are up against we always say
there's no stories but like jackie said
there's gonna come a day where we
actually have zero stories and like
today might be like one of those days
today's not the day we figured our way
around it but i'm just letting you know
i want you guys to know how dire things
are getting so people magazine has three
stories
with pictures and then they have their
trending now so these are the three the
big top story of the day princess
charlene hospitalized released in stable
condition after medical emergency now we
hope she's okay but we don't know who
she is i do not know her but i believe
she's the princess of south africa
that's what i'm niche well she's eager
to return home from south africa oh she
was in south africa so what's she the
princess of i'm gonna go with greece
okay i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna
click it
wow clickbait the princess of
i motto
i don't i don't know it's buried too
deep okay
then dr addison montgomery is back kate
walsh is returning to grey's anatomy for
season 18. okay i have to say even
though like we could not have given less
of a shred of a [ __ ]
this is like big news for a lot of
people who are obsessed with grey's
anatomy so even though i personally
don't care i am happy for those who do
care okay i've just never heard of dr
addison that's her character's name i
know but like even still i've heard of
dr mcsteamy
yeah
yeah both of them yeah they're steamy
and dreamy yeah i've heard of them
okay then david crosby calls former band
nate neil young probably the most
selfish person i know i mean i'm sorry
to this man if i knew who these people
were it sounds like an interesting story
i'm sorry but i don't yeah so there's
very little going on hold on now the
trending now top four stories okay
one
vote for the world's cute cutest rescue
dog
oh maybe i'll do that in my personal
yeah
number two mtv renews jersey shore
family vacation for season five okay a
story number two trending trending
number three and i think this one got
cut me the deepest
a hand standing spotted skunks are
considered the acrobats of their
ever-growing species
and then number four a dog named storm
interrupts the weather report segment to
look for treats that's adorable
you know that's what we're trying to
like really like
impress upon you guys is that is such a
slow news day so we figured we'd just
talk about ourselves for a little while
before diving into the mindlessness that
is today's news but we do we do have
five stories and and
they came together but it was a fight
there's five of them there's five and
they're probably going to be fast but
you never know some i mean we'll make do
we literally always do we've been doing
this for so long this isn't the first
slow news day yeah but it certainly
won't be the last and i'm just coming
off the heels of feeling invigorated
because i got a huge michaela recharge
last night we were able to have dinner
with her and i'm just feeling so much
better like so invigorated with the
spirit of kay yeah she can do that to
you no truly she was being so twisted
last night like just looking so [ __ ]
cute in her custom denim jacket she's
insane she's insane like with her belly
out eating pretzel sticks like
do you ever think about like if you
could trade lives with anyone who would
you want to trade lies with
because i'm sure people say like kylie
jenner like i say michaela shapiro
i say dude
oh my god i actually think about that
all the time like at least michaela is
gonna you know you know poo poo not
gonna like grow up and have real
problems like everyone else right theo
will never have real problems he doesn't
even have like a subconscious like i aim
to be as like free willy as theo and
theo could be living in a palace or be
living in a dump and to him it's all the
same like he has this kind of
equilibrium i don't know if that's the
right word but i'm jealous of it yeah no
it's an inner peace that you will never
achieve never no matter how many colors
oh my god no matter how many coloring
books i buy how many puzzles you do i
will never achieve the level of inner
peace that theo currently possesses and
that's something i have to live with
that's my cross to bear a hundred
percent because at the end of the day
even if i reach like my peak
peacefulness like i am still a human
being like with a brain and like i'll
never just be able to completely unplug
like that like theo has yeah so i always
think like who do i want to be i want to
be theo do you want to be bruno oh
brutal he lives the life but you know
what i feel like root to do i mean he's
about to have one of the best weekends
of his life because it's a lot of time
with his lady friend knowles
um and that's all he ever wants like i
could take him here i could take him
there like machu picchu taj mahal and
he's like but is magnolia coming and i'm
like no like she's not
so this weekend we're staying in with
knowles watching check shrek 3 and shrek
4.
there's a fourth
wow that's a lot it's a lot of shreks we
watched two last night it was really
good but bruno was actually in the other
room for most of it so he missed like
the entire plot and i was like i'm not
catching you up it's too complex
um he missed possum boots and you know
what pus also like
i remembered him like it's just so much
more of a man than he was
in boots who's in boots
how do you mean like i just remembered
him as like the star
but it's really it's donkey's show but
puss in boots gets his own movie yeah no
and post in boots like has you know
charisma charisma and he has this thing
going on um
but i don't know as i've gotten older
i'm just like
it's donkey you're saying puss is not
the main character no and
he's cute like he's super cute and he
has his moments but
he like
he was coming for donkey like him and
shrek where like puss and check were
like talking [ __ ] about donkey in front
of donkey like trying to make him feel
bad i'm just like justice for donkey
he's such a good friend but i have to
say re-watching the films is an adult
with like an enormous heart i've been
told um
it's really justice for donkey donkey is
this like wonderfully
positive good spirited person
and even in the beginning like
ogrelicious is so mean to him
and he's just like nothing can take down
his positive energy like in the morning
i'm making waffles like he just cannot
be brought down shrek let down your
walls let him make you waffles like an
episode of the bachelor like put your
walls down yeah so justice for donkey
put your layers down peel back those
layers and donkey but donnie does that
if anyone was gonna get through to shrek
it was gonna be donkey so he's just so
integral to the story and
i just i have a softer place in my heart
for him i i'm really appreciative of
your insights on the matter yeah so i'll
keep you posted on trek the third and
the fourth i just want to share
something because we said the word
charisma before and it reminded me of
something so there's this thing on
rupaul's drag race where rue when he's
sending someone home or just like
describing a queen he'll always say like
you've got charisma uniqueness nerve and
talent and it's just like a great way i
thought to like describe a person it's
so nice like a performer i have been
watching the show for like over a year
now and i've seen literally every
episode and i just realized that when he
says charisma uniqueness nerve and
talent c-unt yeah okay like i literally
did not realize that up until like
yesterday
also the drag race all-star season six
winner was announced yesterday i didn't
watch it yet so please don't spoil it
but the season is twisted and not in a
good way just like a ragtag group like
i'm still behind i still haven't watched
a snatch game
but that's neither here nor there okay
we'll keep us posted um i also am like
30
of the way through this book that you
recommended the lion's den like it's
getting better i just like it might have
been me yesterday like i was not in a
good reading space and i couldn't get i
don't think it's reflective of the book
i think it's reflective of the space
well the book
i can understand where you're knowing
what i know now like where you're at
like there's
there's still so much you need to to get
through and experience so but i think
the payoff is worth all this time you're
putting in yeah i don't plan on not
finishing it it's just not the type of
thing where like i literally can't go to
bed until i finish it yeah because there
it's it starts out like you think it's
just like a dull stupid book about like
two friends a trip yeah yeah but it
takes
many a turn but it's just like i
this is not a spoiler alert but
basically this girl goes on this like
big fancy trip with her friend who's
like dating this billionaire and it's
like a torturous trip and it's like so
true like literally you could be on like
a private jet on a private yacht in the
middle of the mediterranean and still be
having the worst [ __ ] time yeah
that's the message i've taken away so
far yeah no and her friend is a torturer
torturer the whole thing and her friend
is being tortured by a bigger torture
yeah so
like the manicures the manicures yeah
craziness so i'm enjoying it like it's
not um
grabbing me gripping me yet but i think
i'll get there okay cool i'm excited for
you that you have that ahead of you
otherwise this weekend i'm just gonna be
enjoying the long weekend watching the
shreks as i mentioned hanging with the
kids
and
yeah i'm still reading my book empty
mansions it's really dragging but i'm
gonna finish it also this is a long
weekend obviously because of labor day
but we are also off tuesday you guys
it's rosh hashanah so happy new year to
all of our jewish toasters monday and
tuesday is rosh hashanah so we will
unfortunately not be doing shows but
we'll be back on wednesday yes and happy
new year everyone and you know like the
second we get to rosh hashanah we are a
hop a skip and a breath away from young
people and you know what i feel like
this entire time well not the entire
time but like since you've been like
outward like outwardly pregnant i feel
like i've really just been able to
relate to you on a totally deeper
level but the fact that you won't be not
will not be able to like commiserate
with me on yom kippur like makes me hate
you yeah that i'm not like dreading yom
kippur like it's not in the back of your
mind sounds like an exciting day like
what am i going to do that day what am i
going to eat that's disgusting no but i
still have to atone and repent of course
of course you know when i still and like
i still i can't you know
wear leather shoes right or like go to a
party yeah or like fragrances but you'll
be able to eat and that's really the
only thing that matters ever i agree
gotta get me you think it's i have
enough time to get pregnant
before you keep working yeah uh
no no no what should i thought about
that you should have well i think we
have a decent show so i think we can get
right into it i think i really
i know that we can you know
i just we've never not we've never known
so without further ado
it is time for the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
our patreon channel patreon.com morning
toast is our subscription service so
this show is free on youtube and
podcasts but if you're looking for more
content from your two favorite gals you
could pay 7.99
every month to get five extra episodes
from us and those episodes are podcasts
their vlogs you can request stuff and
also that's 7.99 gets you entry into our
last remaining facebook group the toast
after dark which is for patreon members
only so again that's patreon.com the
morning toast to get
five extra episodes a month a great way
to get more content from us and to
support your local podcast so
patreon.com
the morning toast
great our first story drake drops his
sixth studio album called certified
certified lover boy after a month's long
delay
so certified lover boy is here drake's
six studio album it includes artists
such as jay-z travis scott lil wayne
future young thug 21 savage ty dolla
sign kid cuddy rick ross little baby and
project pat and nicki minaj um
interesting that the album finally drops
the same week as kanye's when you know
as we've said they've been beefing and
zach is huge fan of both of the both
drake and kanye zak is like stuck
between two friends like i am with
taylor and kim yeah it would be like
if taylor and kim like both put out an
album yeah so
and he listened to donda when it came
out and he actually didn't love it that
much really yeah he like and he was so
excited for it but i think probably will
grow on him but whatever i liked it
then he last night he was like love her
boys coming out like it's gonna be so
good and then this morning he said that
actually he listened to his album and
like that dondo is better well the thing
is donda broke all these records and i'm
curious because it's only been like 12
hours since drake's come out
if by like tomorrow we'll know if drake
broke the records that kanye just broke
i don't think that he will i don't
really think that he will either um i
personally won't be listening to the
album and also like the album cover
that's really going viral all the
pregnant women like still no redhead and
by the way there is a redhead emoji now
so here's the deal with the redhead
emoji there is one redhead emoji you can
go scroll through the thousands of
emojis and find a redhead but on all of
the people emojis you get variations
haircuts hair colors skin colors it's a
beard and they're there's not the
redhead option in all of like in bride
yeah in this queen in everything yeah
the truckers for redheads are [ __ ]
pregnant lady and i'm not represented
red-headed pregnant lady so true it's
disgusting
yeah also like i love that everyone was
sharing this album cover but i think we
can all kind of come together and agree
like this is not an innovative album
cover like emojis
yeah i mean but it was like everyone was
doing it and it went no i know spritz
did it yeah i'm just saying like it's a
concept for an album cover like a highly
anticipated album i don't know like lil
nas x just came out with like the most
sickening album cover of all time him
pregnant no that wasn't his
album cover that was like a press thing
like i'm pregnant with my new album but
his album covers like he's in this
gorgeous it kind of looks like lisa
frank like enchanted waterfall forest
and his body just completely naked is
like laying
like in the middle of the forest oh i
have to check it out it's really really
cool
um and so i think that's insane you see
gorgeous yeah let me see if make sure
yeah gorgeous very lisa lisa frank great
call so i don't know i just thought this
album cover was like meh you could have
made it on like canva yeah not that
there's anything wrong with canva i feel
that and i don't understand uh the
meaning of it but just i haven't tried
or attempted to or at least even listen
to the album yeah i'm like when it comes
to drake i'm not an album listener i'm
more of like what song's the most
popular i'll listen to the one i'm more
about what songs can't i avoid on the
radio right i'll eventually listen to
you guys god's plan
god's plan i'm just like really not a
big drake fan i think i actually went to
a dre concert with zach
once because i'm a nice wife that is
really nice and um i really didn't enjoy
myself uh but like
you guys went with like the big stage
that was like an iphone right yeah we at
but like i remember before i was a kanye
fan like i went with him to um
the life of pablo because i was being
just like a supportive girlfriend and
even though i wasn't a fan at the time
like i enjoyed myself immensely yeah uh
what you guys know one of my biggest
regrets in this life i have two not
getting in that police car and second
not going to life a public concert i was
like ben let me get tickets he's like no
let me take care of it i'm like okay the
night comes i'm on instagram everyone's
at the concert and i'm in my bed like
how did i get here
life regret yeah what's your biggest
regret
oh you're agreeing to host a show with
me no going on that teen tour oh yeah
wasting a summer of high school years
yeah
that's a good one yeah i never went on a
team because you know that not going on
it wouldn't have changed like i in
general i've made a lot of mistakes in
my life but i wouldn't change because
what i've learned and where i'm at of
course etcetera etcetera but that's
something that wouldn't have changed the
course of my life and i just would have
had a more enjoyable summer no like if
you
didn't go on that teen tour you might we
might not be sitting here you just never
know okay but i feel certain the
butterfly effect i feel certain we'd be
sitting here
i don't know like i don't think anything
like would have happened that summer
that would have stopped me from like
being the person that i am today i don't
know like maybe like you would have been
doing fabulous things that summer and i
would have like driven out to meet you
and then i would have gotten in a car
accident and i'd be dead
it's impossible okay it's possible you
see what i'm saying i and now i do see
what you're saying so we're happy for
drake
happy for drake
next story a little more album news
peppa the pig was just trolling kanye
west on twitter after getting a better
album review
then who then kanye so
the pigs album has a 6.5
on music review site pitchfork and i
should say and kanye's has a 6.0 and so
peppa's official twitter posted on
wednesday saying peppa didn't need to
host listening parties in the
mercedes-benz stadium to get that 0.5
followed by a dropped microphone and an
oink emoji peppa's pep is a savage i
just have to say i there there are
certain publications like i've never
read but just despise and pitchfork is
one of them i feel like they're always
coming for taylor swift like i just i
think
i think they're like a a website that
prides himself on like hating popular
things you know and that's like that's
why people hate taylor swift like
because she's popular you know i guess i
mean i just feel like a website it seems
a little reductive but oh for sure um
the fact that they would rate peppa the
pig is 6.5 i'm looking at them
differently differently and i'm like
respect differently yeah
it's like what are they right mickey
mouse clubhouse because those bops are
awesome because that's a lot of [ __ ]
tests
m-i-c-k
m-o-u-s-e
we're going on a trip on our favorite
rocket ship zooming through the sky
little einstein we're going on a trip on
our favorite galaxy ship swimming
through the sky little einstein
beautiful what other songs does
one thing i've learned about welcoming a
child into my life michaela
is my calling that i completely missed
out on is doing the vocals for like
fisher-price like toys that sing or any
of these shows like i think that like
the voices are so annoying like that's
so me and like when michaela opens and
it's like a abc like that should be me
it's not too late i know who like where
does one go to get into this field i
don't know whose door do i have to knock
on i don't know but you should really
pursue it because that would be so
fantastic for you like to really get out
your creative juices and then like and
it'll be good for the kids because you
do have an annoying beautiful voice and
the kids like will associate with my
voice forever and i will just become
like a piece of you know early 2000s
nostalgia yeah
and then like in a few years you'll be
in a documentary and like i'll make a
tick tock and i'll be like hi guys
remember ray and i'll go viral finally
you'll finally have a lot of time credit
tick-tock fame that you've been shining
for totally
because you know like there's this girl
on tick tock and she was the voice
original voice of dora and she like
hates it she won't do it
so do you hate her hate but she did one
video she's like hi guys
and it went so viral it was like really
it was her it was like watching dora it
was crazy and she's my inspiration that
is a really good goal for you i think if
you play your cards right in
20 years you will be tick tock famous i
just need like a toaster whose dad is
big at fisher price or something to like
just open a door for me there's like a
lot of
of kids programming these days like
so miss obviously mickey mouse clubhouse
but like no offense that's the creme de
la creme it's disney junior
yeah but but they have like those roles
are locked up spoken for spoken for okay
but there's coco melon even though i
watched two minutes of cocoa melon and
it was so
dumb yeah and it's like this is bad for
the children yeah and because like
mickey like mickey's a pilot mickey's a
farmer he's showing you how to plant
seeds grow trees like you're learning
things from mickey how are we going to
fly this plane like oh toodles
but coco melons
i have no idea what cocoa melon is cocoa
melon's like a kids program that's
really really popular and kay likes it
but it's too dumb it's like i walked in
the door i put my foot in front of the
other foot sounds good my next
i went to my desk and i took out my
chair and i sat in the chair like i get
it it's
so mind-numbingly dumb and i think it's
it's not a good influence is it disney
cocoa melon no it's i don't know who
makes cocoa melon and who makes peppa
pig
peppa pig that's british peppa and i
haven't watched peppa the pig but the
stories that have emerged about american
kids speaking in british language
british accents because they're
influenced by peppa i think is so
beautiful yeah and i think that kay
needs to start watching peppa me too for
sure
i'm not sure
who makes coco melon
i'm not sure and what channel is peppa
on
i don't know where you can find peppa
back in the day it was channel 31 or 33
disney or nickelodeon but now like the
options yeah now you have like three
kids youtube kids so you have cocoa
melon you have baby sharks
i bet like the toasters who are moms are
like please stop singing that song or
they're like can't get in here but it
low-key slaps i just want to say sorry
to all the moms but
baby you're on your own on this one
[Music]
okay that's enough that's enough thank
you kevin that's enough
anyways peppa the pig came for kanye oh
right that was the story and they
dropped the mic and you know what i i
think it's hysterical yeah
i really do
okay are you ready for our next story it
is a little biz
news a little
bus news i'm ready
reddit is seeking to hire advisors to go
public in a us ipo apparently they'll be
trading under the ticker e v i o l o l
that's funny honestly i usually support
ingenuity and companies going public i
[ __ ] hate reddit it gave a platform
to trolls and i just i literally only
wish for them to fail um i know i don't
know one positive thing reddit has
brought to our culture for real
it's just given power to losers keyboard
warriors like
i don't know okay but say like here i'm
reading this article one thing reddit
was responsible for was the um like
gamestop that's true amc thing and like
you know the wall street bets which was
like
very
cool time yeah i guess maybe i have like
a really negative like hole in my heart
for reddit because the first time like
before i was even remotely popular on
the internet my first bout of like
negative
um
press if you will was with a reddit sub
when i used to write blog posts that
were like hella offensive i wrote this
whole thing about how it like sucks to
be a guy who's short because like i
don't know like if you're ugly but like
you're rich like anything can help like
guys like get girls unless you're short
like you're just short forever and i
guess somebody found the blog post and
put it on a sub threaded
sub community called r shorts which is
for short people and i remember i was on
my blog like just you know maintaining
the blog my google analytics was like
there's 2000 people on your website and
i had never had more than like three
people on my blog
and it was all this traffic from reddit
people were leaving comments like for me
to kill myself like i was so i was
quaking that was like the first time i
ever had like negative
interactions on the internet because no
one was reading my blog
and maybe that's why i just feel like a
little towards reddit i just feel like
the amount of people who tell you to
kill yourself on reddit every day is if
i had a nickel
yeah it's a crazy crazy platform it is
and i feel like it also like inspired
all those other types of
forum type websites that are even worse
than reddit like 4chan you know
i don't know if there would be a 4chan
if there weren't a reddit
yeah
yeah but it's also just people yeah it's
just a dark corner of the internet in my
opinion yeah like it could be people
sharing recipes and improving on them no
there are there are good the love island
usa subreddit is a fabulous place to be
right but like it's the people so
the platform just yes it is technology
if you're an inherently negative person
i just feel like the platform you
probably gravitate towards is reddit yes
definitely and if you're like you know
have no balls because right you're not
anonymous because you're right
it's like say it say your face say it
with your face literally and call me
ugly girl you gotta send a pic
anyways reddit is potentially going
public so look out for it on the stock
market
that was a funny joke evil thank you
thanks so much i mean it's a good idea
if they need a ticket yeah i love when
people get like creative with their
ticker like what we when we reported
that uh chewy
woof that's so cute so [ __ ] cute the
morning toast were to go public
rdh
[Laughter]
yeah that's good even though tmt yeah of
course
um but do you need four or three suffice
oh i don't work in finance i don't know
i feel like it's probably three weeks in
the morning toast
tmt yeah or rdh okay next in some other
biz news
the mcdonald's mcflurry machine is
broken and now the ftc is on it took
them long enough
i don't know i don't know this is a
really like it's a funny headline but
then it's like what is the ftc doing
also wait can we talk about the ftc
because isn't the ftc also like if you
don't use hashtag ad like they they sued
jlo because she put up an ad like a few
years ago for fifty thousand dollars
and
you're telling me the same company that
sue's jlo is the same company that
investigates some ice cream machines the
federal trade commission so they're
investigating all trade i guess and
that's kind of just like biz things
right
the ftc has reached out to mcdonald's
franchisees seeking information about
what exactly is going on with reports of
broken ice cream machines after years of
public outcry franchise owners have long
complained that the machines are overly
complicated hard to fix and time
consuming to clean mcdonald's said it
understands the frustration and is
working on the problem
that's it
yeah and there
the ftc is looking into it for everyone
well i'm not gonna lie like is this a
cause i can get behind absolutely yes
but it also it must mean the rest of the
world is perfect if this is what we're
focusing on right like honestly
mcdonald's is a near-perfect institution
like really like except
except for the founding and the founder
yeah but it's almost as i've seen that
movie you've gotta watch it's almost as
if they're one ice cream machine short
of perfection so like
i think we need to relax a little bit of
course it is frustrating um but i'm glad
to hear that everything else in the biz
world is up to code and now that the so
the ftc can be focusing on this that
means everything is going great i love
mcdonald's me too so much and i've not
that i often get
ice cream at mcdonald's i usually get a
mcflurry yeah but that's the same
machine is it it has to be
for sure yeah because like that seems
like a waste of space because it's
vanilla ice cream and then when you get
a vanilla
swirler right it's just like dizzy's it
up
okay so i'll go back to what i was about
to say i've never tried to get a
mcflurry
and was stymied and said the machine was
broken no i've definitely i feel like
you go to mcdonald's like very
infrequently now that you're pregnant
you're probably doing it more but like
some of us have like gears in this you
know industry yeah no i'm i'm not i'm
not
discounting anybody else's experience
i'm only talking about my own experience
yes and my experience is definitely i
would say like 75 of the time it's fine
and also my experience at mcdonald's
they're very
you know
random like at a different like
mcdonald's here mcdonald's they're over
different courses it's not like every
time i go to mcdonald's i go to the same
one it's actually quite the opposite no
and by the way mcdonald's in the city
are the worst like i mean i've been
ordering from the one that's near me and
just the quality control there is yeah
like if you want a good mcdonald's like
you get in the car and you go to a
drive-through but like the ones in the
city are just like barely like they're
good enough but they're not great like i
always bend into the chicken finger
being like okay where's the finger now
like i just know that it's in there
excuse me
so those are the fast four stories and
for our fifth story
we have a bit of
kelly's mindless news like the fourth of
july
kelly's mindless news is no way
associated with kelly ripper herself we
apologize in advance any offense it may
cause but we are personally offended by
the mindlessness that circulates on the
internet courtesy of kelly ripa's
publicity team so we got tagged in this
so many times on instagram and i'm so
glad that like when people see a
mindless piece of news about kelly ripa
like their first association us that
makes me feel great and that we're doing
really important work here and today's
mindless news is especially mindless
okay here's the headline from people
magazine kelly rip and people magazine
is the breeding ground of mindless news
that and hello magazine
kelly ripa claps back at claims she used
a filter in a beach selfie quote it's
just the angle
now i think we should unpack the
title really quickly because
i don't really know what an angle and a
filter
have to do with one another they don't
okay that was just apples and oranges on
wednesday the live with kelly and ryan
co-host 50 shared a selfie of herself
and her husband mark zuelos enjoying a
sunset on the beach she is looking
timeless without the help of a filter
she shared a selfie of herself and
husband mark enjoying a sunset on the
beach they were all smiles as they
lounged in their chairs on the sand i
thought the picture was very sweet it
was really cute yeah
with the mom of three implying in the
caption that they brought cheese and a
baguette to share
wow that's so cute
many of ripa's followers commented on
her and consuelos's youthful appearances
in the photo you too you two look like
teenagers one person wrote that's nice
however another apparently swore that
ripa did some photo editing to the snap
in a now deleted comment oh well if they
swore yeah somebody wrote i love how
like one
moron's comment is in people magazine
story it's [ __ ] crazy but like we
can't get in right we can't literally
here's the comment that the person wrote
how is it you look 10 years younger
kelly raised eyebrow emoji must be a
relaxing holiday
honestly that doesn't even seem like a
shady comment not enough to warrant a
clap
right in an article like like yeah
that's like that's kind of like funny
and cute like how a mom to you like then
someone else wrote someone else wrote as
beautiful as she is it's def a filter
how little is going on in kelly ripa's
life like this is actually getting to
her no and yeah that she even responds
to this
and we know how little is going on in
the world of celebrity news which is why
people magazine writes it up ripa fired
back
at the assumption writing if it was a
filter i would look amazing it's just
the angle and sunset light as of
wednesday afternoon her response still
appears on the post but the comments
have been limited
so this is literally the biggest
oh okay and then oh wow she's really
doubling down like no offense she looks
nice in this picture like that's what
she looks like she doesn't look like
insanely like no and like when someone
uses a filter and like an overweight
like you can tell and it just it looks
like kelly ripley so then on her
instagram story she reshared the photo
but she made a pic stitch basically
of her original photo and then her with
a filter like she literally used face
app and put like makeup on so she
reshared the photo alongside another
version that had a filter over it in the
filtered version her face is clearly
smoother gives off the appearance that
kelly ripa is wearing a full face of
makeup and she wrote spot the difference
it's about the difference um adding a
thinking emoji so she's just really
bothered by the fact that like
this
person this is such an intricate story
like there's so many layers about
nothing about nothing and i feel
inspired by the story to go around and
leave mean comments on celebrities
instagrams because then maybe i'll get
written up no and then i could like
start a business yeah no like i'll get
press and like apparently that's all you
have to do
to be like this just said
because it's like what about all the
nice comments saying how beautiful she
looked and it's like oh no if you're
mean you will get kelly rip his
attention go for it
and honestly it's like sometimes khloe
kardashian will respond to haters
because they say like the most evil vile
things about chloe literally all they're
saying is that you look too beautiful
kelly like calm the [ __ ] down but i also
have like it's a
it's a chicken and egg situation i also
blame the publications because they like
live to write up so and so collapse back
yeah online troll so celebrities are
like i want to be the so-and-so who
clapped back at an online troll i'm like
oh i'll get my name in the paper today
if i just clap back let me find the
meanest comment i just have to say
though and by the way that's the word
troll here is being used like really
unnecessarily like this woman literally
called her so beautiful
kelly has such a hard life
no but it's crazy because i would say
kelly ripa like works really hard has so
many jobs like never stops yet somehow
she has too much time on her hands
literally
literally well that's your kelly's
mindless news of the day and we hope you
enjoyed the mindlessness of that segment
and this entire show in particular
yeah but you know sometimes you just
gotta take your mind off things with a
little mindless and it's a nice friday
we don't want to carry anything too
heavy today exactly now you know you can
go into the weekend really prepped and
there's really nothing going on so we
get invited to a dinner party like you
don't have to worry about being caught
up on like someone's ipo you know read
it read it yes
so that's our show you guys and that was
our week and we'll be back on wednesday
because a reminder monday and tuesday
are labor day and rosh hashanah so happy
new year
to all of our jewish toasters and those
who celebrate and we hope you have an
amazing weekend stay safe and thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so spotify
at youtube stitcher public radio i have
radio cat box all the places so if you
listen to podcast find us in the morning
shows leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you're still listening to this leave
an emoji associated with the beach
because kelly and justice for her on the
beach okay okay bye bye
you